we all know who Superman is but who is
Clark Kent
life is pretty crazy for comic book
characters but things have really gotten
nuts for Superman
recent events even have longtime reader
scratching their heads here's what's
been happening back in 2011 DC
relaunched her comic universe with the
new 52 all the characters were younger
and had small changes to their past in
history the new 52 version of Superman
recently died sacrificing himself
fighting a foe
luckily the world wasn't left without a
Man of Steel as the Superman from the
4-2 new 52 started found himself in a
current timeline this Superman is
married to Lois Lane and they have a son
John the Superman made a public
appearance when Lex Luthor declared
himself metropolis new Superman the
discussion between the two was cut short
by the appearance of doomsday during the
battle
Clark Kent appeared on the scene the
world had recently discovered Clark Kent
and Superman were the same person
but this guy was adamant that he was not
and never was Superman to further drive
the point home Pett broke his arm during
Doomsday's rampage we're all left asking
who the heck is this Clark Kent guy Kent
claims Superman warned him about a story
he was working on exposing the secrets
of a genetic crime corporation would be
deadly to prove he's who he says he was
Kent even took a lie-detector test which
was secretly run by Batman and passed
continuing his research on a genetic Ron
corporation he was stored off the roof
of the building by a security guard
thankfully Superman was there in time to
catch Kent we'll have to wait and see
what happens next
be sure to check back on gamespot
universe for all your entertainment news
including crazy Superman updates